il n'est peut être l'air de rien comme
ça de bon matin et pourtant françois
hadji lazaro qui freinent estate est
comme un esthète
il sait apprécier les bonnes choses et
d'autres un troisième étage d'arrivée 20
entièrement fait de façon bio bresson au
cutter des vins et vigneault jeunes qui
durent pas longtemps se boire vite et
son état frites est super bon
relationnel
mais cet artiste n'a pas fait que goûter
aux plaisirs de la bouche
en vérité ces tonnes et le bowling
l'aide
en 15 ans de carrière france ô a dit
ladjia rom de se séparer de saint claude
dans son antre caché quelque part dans
les hauteurs de parler l'ogre musicien a
appris à jouer d'une vingtaine
d'instruments différents musées des
barbaries accordéon guitare une
mayonnaise en plaine de la crau mail ou
de russie maire de londres ont diverses
et variées aussi berthier en typique
d'un instrument qu'est né en europe de
l'est est aussi dans les vosges que la
famille de l'épinette des auges tient
pas là sans atlantique en avant dans les
appalaches s'est transformé en du cimer
au total de 1984 cet artiste hors norme
pourra participer à des duels de
bientôt aux côtés de roland pt gauche et
il aura beau but est que monsieur en
concert paix dans le monde
et cet enfant de cette cour parisienne
que françois hadji-lazaro investit aussi
beaucoup de son énergie boucherie
productions et une maison de 10 à
l'image de son créateur vaste et coloré
puis il faut croire c'est s'appelait 150
albums encaissé produits les cassettes
continuent d'affluer alors ça dépend des
jours sur l'année donc ses 1200 à peu
près moyenne de trois par jour
les groupes véritable sur les artistes
véritable ils savent plus trop signé
donc nous reçoit dans la manche aux
balançoires une du classique du jazz ce
que les gens savent plus aussi nié y
compris amener certaines références
ça fait trop de maisons de disques
un premier jour de disney carrière solo
la petite entreprise de prendre l'eau et
du lait de la route
il ya les ivrognes équipe
si franche pas une enfant le loup mais
bon
parfait